democratic presidential nominee joe
biden says
americans will not allow the president
not to accept the results of the
november election
his first tv interview alongside his
running mate senator kamala harris aired
on abc last night
the latest latest cbs news poll finds
last week's virtual democratic
convention
increased the number of voters excited
about supporting biden
rather than voting against the president
ed o'keefe
is covering campaign 2020.
after an unprecedented democratic
national convention joe biden spent the
weekend at his delaware beach home
he isn't expected to make many public
appearances as the republican national
convention is held this week
but in his first joint television
interview with running mate senator
kamala harris
biden defended his mostly virtual
campaign schedule
saying it's a strategy that will work
we've been able to travel places when
we've been able to do it in a way that
we don't cause the congregation of large
numbers of people
look what happens what's happened with
his his
events people die people get together
they don't wear masks they end up
getting covered they end up dying
biden was also asked about some of his
controversial comments specifically
about race but i tell him if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or
trump and you ain't black i shouldn't
have said that
but i was trying to make the point that
this is a man who spent
his entire career denigrating
african-americans
but the truth is there's a fundamental
difference
between donald trump and me on the issue
of
race across the board i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna
try to divide people harris who's
criticized by their stance on racial
issues in the past
said she knows where his heart is when
joe and i talked about the state of
black america
he has a deep sense of awareness and
knowledge
about racial disparities inequities and
systematic racism
in that interview biden also didn't rule
out running for a second term that's
notable because if he wins in november
he'd be 77 the oldest person ever
elected president
and he's never gone quite as far in
suggesting he'd be up for it again
in 2024 one other note this morning the
binding campaign says
27 former gop lawmakers are now
endorsing the former vice president's
campaign
they include senator former senator jeff
flake of arizona and former senator
john warner of virginia gail all of this
coming of course the morning that the
republican convention
is set to begin yeah it's another late
night for all of us
you too ed o'keefe i'll be watching
can't wait thank you very much ed
always good to see you